.
Danielle Kadjo.
- Dans le viseur de Moscou
depuis plusieurs semaines,
le sort de l'ONG Mémorial
est désormais connu.
toutes ses activités,
tel que l'ordonne  d d d d d d .
On lui reproche de ne pas
s'identifier comme un agent
étranger, qui, pourtant,
a bien des aelelelelelelelelele.
Dans la Russie de Vladimir
Poutine, ce statut est
controversé.
Il désqui recoivent des fonds
étrangers et qui, donc,
selon Moscou agissent
contre les intérêts russes.
"C'e
injuste et très nuisible pour
nopapapays", réagit l'avocate
de la défense.
avancé est insuffissant
urururur ordonner la dissolution
d'un organisme à but
non lu
ONG emblématique, Mémorial
est la principale organisatienes
humains. Elle enquête
depuis plus de 30 ans
sur les crimes soviétiques,
contemporaines, dont celles
égégégégime de Valdimir Poutine.
En plus de la loi dite violée,
le parquet l'accapapapapapapapat
de l'extrémisme.
(en russe)
Une manifestation a d'ailleurs
lalalalaté devant le palais
de justice. Au moins cinq
manifestantspar la police, seloa
indépendant russe Sota Vision.
Cette décision de la Cour
suprême vient conclure
la repression croissante
des critiques du président
Vladimir Poutine, au pouvoir
de
Deux alliés de l'opposant russe
emprisonné, Alexeinynynynyny,
ont d'ailleurs été arrêtés
mardi, dont une élue, Kseniarér,
un crime passible de 12 ans
d'emprisonnement. Pour sa part,
l'ONG Mémorial refuse de baisser
des moyens légaux de poursuivre
ses ac
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Montréa